many of you are not going to believe
what I'm going to tell you today unless
you've actually been following this
story in which case you will absolutely
believe it YouTube's demonetised 75% of
our video clips that we uploaded
yesterday from yesterday's program
yesterday's show that we did for you
which we spent all day producing of
course in filming and editing and all of
that stuff contained eight separate
clips that we uploaded to YouTube and
upon uploading them six of the eight or
75% were instantly demonetised by
YouTube's algorithms 75% of the work we
did yesterday the content that we spent
all day producing was in a fraction of a
second deemed not advertisers friendly
and thus unable to earn any revenue for
us on YouTube so I want to be really
clear here about what I am saying and
about what I'm not saying I'm not saying
that we have a legal issue on our hands
here let me be clear I'm not saying
YouTube can't choose to monetize or not
to monetize whatever they want but let
me also be clear that we're playing by
the rules and this is not how the system
is supposed to work
we don't do profanity on our channel we
don't do violent and gory images we
don't harass people on the basis of
their sexual orientation or other
characteristics we don't bully people we
don't Doc's people or anything like that
we produce FCC safe progressive news and
commentary and while we're supposedly
playing by all of YouTube's rules more
and more of our content as being
demonetised so yesterday we produced the
show we paid salaries to our staff we
paid studio rent
we paid utilities we paid connectivity
we paid health insurance but the clips
75% of them make no money on YouTube
hundreds of thousands of views yesterday
from these clips that make no money on
YouTube so this is a systemic issue and
notice bi I don't want to be misquoted
there are articles that now are there
are media outlets following my coverage
of what's going on on YouTube and they
have started to misquote what I am
saying I am NOT saying we are being be
monetized for being left-wing or
progressive okay the right has preached
sob stories for a year
about the anti right-wing bias on
YouTube and everywhere else I am NOT
saying this is anti left-wing bias the
evidence that I've found is that this is
anti independent bias and pro corporate
bias within the news and politics space
on YouTube so I think I just have to
kind of get real with you here about the
situation I had to reach out to our
partners this week and basically say
this may never be resolved okay this may
simply be the new normal and we need to
kind of reposition our expectations
around the reality that this may never
be fixed because again I don't think
YouTube believes anything is broken
I don't believe YouTube thinks there is
anything to fix here this is the system
they want because it's safe for them
because their advertisers like it
there's also what appears to be a
growing issue of people being
unsubscribed from our channel and others
that are independent news in politics
and I am seeing this in the analytics
I've received hundreds of emails from
people who say David I've been a
subscriber for a month I've been a
subscriber for a year I've been a
subscriber for five years to your
YouTube channel I went to your channel
today because I didn't notice any of
your videos on my homepage and I noticed
that the subscribe button was enabled
meaning I was able to click Subscribe
because I had somehow been unsubscribed
from your channel now I know a lot of
people are gonna hear me say this and
they'll email me and say David this is
happening to me as well I've already
told you too about it I've told them
about it ten times all I can say is make
sure you're subscribed right now I mean
check right now if you're watching on
YouTube and click the subscribe button
if you aren't if you're listening on the
radio or to the podcast or whatever
consider going to YouTube and
subscribing to our channel there as well
so I'm exploring many other options to
try to deal with this issue that we're
experiencing the most direct is not you
know moving our content to some platform
with no audience sadly I know people
email me they say David start uploading
to X Y or Z website moving our content
to websites where the content isn't
monetized and there's nobody watching is
not a solution to the problem okay
so what's important to understand is if
we didn't have any other revenue sources
we might be in a position to have to
change our story choices in order to
save our revenue and what I mean by that
is if we didn't have revenue coming in
through membership or through patreon I
might have to start each day thinking
okay here's the six stories I want to do
but four of those are likely not to make
any money on YouTube
I guess I'll pick some different stories
I would never want to do that that is
the death of independent media the whole
point here is we cover what we believe
to be important and this is how these
monetization algorithms set the agenda
and drive the narrative by making
certain content financially
unsustainable so that's the freedom that
we get when people support us directly
and as more and more people contribute
via direct membership and patreon you
are basically buying us a little sliver
of immunity from having to even think
about making decisions like here's the
stories I want to cover but they're not
going to make any money maybe I'll pick
some stories that YouTube's algorithm
would find to be brand safe I can't
afford to spend all day researching and
filming and editing and having our staff
do that and pay salaries and health
insurance and rent only to lose out on
the monetization so as I've said it
before I'll say it again the way to fix
this is simply to fund the shows you
like directly okay become a member
ww join pakman.com it's really cheap
it's really quick you get cool stuff but
you buy us immunity from this disastrous
situation that's taking place there is a
discount code for membership this is
20/20 which will save you 40% if you
want to do something else you can go to
patreon.com/scishow especially if you
already are giving to other producers on
patreon throw us a dollar a month throw
us $2 a month it really does make a
difference patreon.com slash david
pakman show